bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j
oggi cominciamo penombra black flag tra
tutti i videogame che avete votato nel
sondaggio su facebook penombra black
flag è stato quello che ha spodestato
l'intero sondaggio praticamente perché
diciamo è stato il titolo che ha
ricevuto più voti in assoluto ne ha
presi quasi 300 tipo una roba del genere
mentre il secondo ne ha presi circa poco
più di cento quindi veramente una cosa
impressionante è veramente vi ringrazio
per aver aver votato per una black flag
così adesso me lo devo pure giocare
maledetti che sia chi va bene a parte
gli scherzi e prima di cominciare la
gara non soltanto dirvi una cosa io di
penombra black flag ho giocato già
diciamo i primi 15 minuti di gameplay
quindi per questo primo episodio quello
che succederà già lo saprò dal prossimo
non sa proprio nulla perché ho già
giocato primi 15 minuti per quelli che
mi seguono da un bel pò di tempo già da
quando facevo video sulle scene di
gaming penombra black flag l'avevo già
iniziato avevo fatto un video solo di 20
minuti in europa del genere e l'avevo
fatto tipo se sei o sette mesi fa quindi
tantissimo tempo fa quindi è passato
veramente un bel po di tempo infatti non
mi ricorderò quasi nulla non dovrei
prendermi infarti esageratamente
incredibili in questo primo episodio
perché appunto
so già più o meno dove andare e cosa
fare per questo primo episodio che va
beh io inizio perché mi sto divulgando
anche troppo nuovo gioco facile normale
difficile andiamo su normale come al
solito senza queste conoscenze senza
questo fondamento non avessi potuto
avere la volontà di fare quello che ti
chiedono di fare mi spinsi fino alle
remote distese della groenlandia ok raga
questo diciamo è la sintesi del primo
capitolo di penombra
simpaticamente siamo andati in
groenlandia per trovare il padre poi
siamo entrati in questo pozzo
giustamente siamo entrati nel pozzo che
vi ricordi è praticamente qui dentro ho
trovato dei cani morti è di poche parole
andata così o cremato il mio migliore
amico red si perché quello era il nostro
migliore amico vi ricordate l'ho fatto
fuori quel bastardo di merd
e vabbè presidente poi siamo scesi nei
bunker e ci hanno stordito e ci hanno
trascinati via non si sa chi è qui ci
eravamo fermati ok vi ho fatto la
sintesi io praticamente ok ci stiamo
svegliando perfetto il soffitto promette
benissimo me lo ricordavo che era così
fantastico si muri poca ruggine mi
dicono in giro comunque ci siamo raga il
primo contatto con il personaggio
principale è sempre un'emozione perché
so che conso stronzo ci devo passare le
pene dell'inferno
bene allora ci programmi in questa
stanza chiusa la porta è chiusa
ovviamente vi dico soltanto una cosa per
quelli che hanno visto penombra overture
è penombra black flag fa paura non è
come overture che ci sono i cani state
tranquilli qui non ci sono cani c'è di
peggio
diciamo ci sono gli stupratori nudi poi
andremo a conoscerli bene purtroppo
allora si congela mi fa piacere e non mi
ricordo già cosa devo fare e l'ho già
fatto pensate quanto sono stupida non
c'è il materasso qualcuno se pisciato
addosso bello c'è una botta da qui che
non si apre
freddo freddo boia e non credo che
questo passo si scaldi ok
beh c'è una moneta si la moneta delle
bibite questa me la ricordavo ok si
allora praticamente qui dietro c'è un
condotto che devo aprire non riuscirò
mai ad allentare le viti senza un
utensile devo infilarci la moneta però è
troppo spessa per far sì che la moneta 5
costano matita che calcolato dal
soffitto il soffitto dà l'impressione di
cross di crollare da un momento
all'altro meglio andarsene da qui mi
sembra un'ottima idea ci hai ragione qua
c'è qualcosa se questa è corta posso
leggere la farà luce l'ombra esiste un
intero mondo
questo mondo necessariamente il nostro
vai via ora è o cosa o gas
come si esce pezzo di carta si pezzo di
qualcos'altro secondo me comunque
apriamo qui ok il bengala ce l'abbiamo
una barra fu una barra fluorescente
comunemente detto bengala potrebbe
servirmi ok poi c'è ace gentile qui e
manca l'ultimo cassetto che non ci
troverà niente perfetto dai usciamo di
qua c'è la pressa devo metterci da
moneta perfetti giriamo come cazzo si
gira qui ok ci sono che farlo sono un
fabbro nato raga
ok ci siamo la moneta è piatta posso
svitare condotto usciamo di qui stile
mission impossible perfetto
direi di accendere tenterò di tenerlo
sempre acceso così almeno ci vedete
qualcosa perché nel primo bisogno perché
nel primo episodio che avevo fatto sul
del gaming non si vedeva proprio una
mazza io direi entrambe le cose non
sapevo cosa sta succedendo è tutta
contratto non me ne importava più nulla
stavo uscendo ma che cazzo dici che ti
sei ficcato nei condotti non sai neanche
noi siamo al centro della terra per
quanto ne sappiamo comunque vabbè
andiamo avanti nei condotti alla solid
snake ci sono le frecce giustamente
buongiorno
ok raga che cos'è è questo e dobbiamo
trovarli un nome io lo chiamerei pif so
perché mi è venuto in mente questo nome
stupido è lui raga sarà lo stupratore
nudo di cui ho parlato è poi più avanti
purtroppo andremo a conoscerlo e qua ci
siamo dei trasportati all indietro non
mi chiedete perché salvation salvation
paio di palle salvezza mia o di chi è
amico di sicuro non tua
ok ci siamo bene c'è una pagina più a
terra come al solito raga io non leggo
una mazza se volete leggere stoppate il
video e vi lascerò sempre qualche
secondo se volete stoppare fate quello
che volete
perché se no il commento di come al
solito durerebbe veramente troppo allora
batterie ok ci siamo ma manca la torcia
cosa ti trovo a fare le batterie c'è
bengala che non mi è servito a nulla
nell'ultimo penombre va beh
e poi c'è la macchina delle bibite e io
vado di coca cola ok ci siamo latina di
soda bene
c'è qualcos'altro dietro che non mi
ricordo non mi pare no ah sì ci sono
delle batterie ok perfetto
ok possiamo andare avanti ci sono ancora
dei condotti si son hanno molto più
veloce dell'ultimo episodio a parte la
premessa di mezz'ora che ho fatto
walsh sex questa me la ricordo mi avevi
[ __ ] l'ultima volta ma adesso non mi
fate ok invece non crolla in teoria
dovrebbe crollare quell'affare velo ve
lo assicuro che dovrebbe crollare
infatti è crollato ok collect set con
l'ex ed un paio di palle non so che cosa
significa ma qua ci sono delle batterie
ok quel crollato tutto è ok perfetto da
per passare praticamente devo portarmi
le travi dietro
ok l'ultimo non mi ricordo se ok
perfetto ce l'ho fatta al primo
tentativo e ci hanno messo un casino mi
ricordo l'ultima volta ok freezer
poi abbiamo gioco e tutti gli altri di
qua non ci posso passare perché devo
chiudere la
la roba qui di vapore dal freezer ok
alla ok questo non me lo ricordavo c'è
un tipo lì fuori e io non ho voglia di
uscire sinceramente buongiorno censura
io sono nel freezer
aprite questa che questa chiusa per
fortuna sì in effetti non è che ci
tenessi più di tanto ad andare di sotto
allora anche qui ci avevo messo un
casino cos'è questo catch up il ketchup
sarà la mia arma di difesa in questo
penombra as ice cosa del freezer un
termostato che controlla la quantità del
liquido refrigerante per le tubature
ok devo prenderla lattine raffreddarlo
anche questo non ricordavo
fortunatamente perché se non avrei perso
mezz'ora ok ci siamo allora abbiamo
tolto la possiamo passare adesso perché
abbiamo chiuso le tubature con la
lattina giustamente e ci siamo ok cielo
c'è un lato o dio c'è un morto ma arrivò
potrei essere io sono le scuse episodi
qui l'etichetta nel nome di cheneil
osvald capo chimici
mi fa molto piacere averti conosciuto
nilo smal sei molto simpatico ma è io me
ne vado di qua sinceramente non lo
voglia di rimanere
[Musica]
e passiamo al senso ci siamo ragazzi c'è
una porta c'è una lavagna non mi ricordo
che
taci sua porca [ __ ] non me lo ricordavo
questo ok non si apre a quanto pare quel
dispositivo dovrebbe essere una specie
di serratura minchia meno male è
sinceramente non la voglio aprire mi fa
molto piacere ma è non ci tengo ad
aprire quella porta non aprite quella
porta
ok devo riuscire a togliere sta roba di
qui perché devo passare raga siamo per
avere il primo incontro state tranquilli
che tra un po arriverà l'azione pura e
andremo a incontrare il nostro pif lo
stupratore nudo
va beh non sarà un incontro piacevole ve
lo dico subito allora è nell'ultimo
penombra
non sapevo che cosa erano sti cosi poi
ti ho trovato una cassetta
ok batteria perfetto nell'ultimo
penombra non sapevo cosa erano sì cosi
ma alla fine lo capitolo a parte la luce
è incredibile servono per salvare c'è
ancora una parte di me che è dentro c'è
qualcosa che mi attira dentro cos'è tipo
una può che vuoi che ti risucchia non
l'ho capito
vabbè c'è altro che già prima cosa è sta
roba alcol
ok dati alla pazza gioia perfetto allora
c'è il lettore dei nastri ho trovato
anche la cassetta quindi ci siamo allora
direi di inserire la cassetta e nel
frattempo che ascolterò questa splendida
registrazione mi sgolo un po di
detersivo ho inserito la cassetta del
registratore giustamente lo devo avviare
però mi è caduto il detersivo chi faccio
a nola nella lettera nella cassetta ma
[ __ ] mi chiami scoppiato un corpo
ok infatti non mi ricordavo che
arrivasse così subito
e meno male perché
non ero pronto diciamo ma che essa porta
è chiusa
il caso c'è qui dentro non lo so è che
c'è del sangue cioè del sap
scommetto che qui dentro c'è un bel po
di roba utile ma la porta è chiusa ok
invece anche questa chiusa e per poterlo
ascoltare raga devo tirare sta roba sul
controcross perfetto sul sta roba qui e
tirare i cavi sono un vandalo perfetto e
adesso staccato la corrente possa aprire
la porta bene posso aprire anche questa
che non mi ricordo si possa aprire anche
questa non mi ricordo sinceramente dove
dovevo andarci un condotto ma io c'ero
passato di quale ultima volta no ma
questo è l'inizio ma la fama minchia
abbia ok ai fatti mi sembrava di averla
già vista sostanza ok
e allora sta roba non serva una minchia
eh vabbè
sì praticamente se torni indietro vi
faccio soltanto presente che il tipo che
prima era seduto sul da aziz sdraiato
sul tavolo
sappiate che il tipo non è più sdraiato
lì vi dico soltanto questo c'è qualcosa
sì c'è una siringa assi che poi mi serve
per aprirla forte ok abbiamo preso la
siringa
ok ci siamo ragazzi ma che diavolo era
dove posso nascondermi beh chiudiamo a
chiudere teoria pronta ok
sta per arrivare più fraga tenetevi
pronti spero che non riesca a sfondare e
mi dico più in basso
cazzo ciao
l'ultima volta mi stava quasi stuprando
adesso se n'è andato non vedi cazzo ok
ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ciao peep show
filmica piacere rivederti mi fa piacere
rivederti pif non sei ingrassato di una
non sei ingrassato per niente
dall'ultima volta ok ok raga tranqui
addio questo sfonda questo sfonda york
no fermo maledetto strong ok prova a
sfondare brutto bastardo bene perfetto
abbiamo fatto la conoscenza del nostro
amico pif
spero che vi sta simpatico perché per me
è simpaticissimo
mi basta scavalcare un secondo prendere
il sangue e tornare ok
dammi perfetto la siringa non si riempie
bloccata la sangue rappreso è
praticamente devo immergerla nell'arco
così la sterilizza e poi posso premi ok
mi però ricorda memoria non è che io non
è che me lo ricordo a memoria che io
sono un chirurgo provetto lo sapete noi
dottor fa vj altro che dottor house
comunque a parte tutto sto casino ce
l'abbiamo fatta e adesso possiamo
entrare qui dentro dove prima
praticamente ha bussato satana alla
porta
ok damon di true blood will get free e
io ce l'ho altra set blog
ok ci siamo ragazzi possiamo entrare
comunque siamo qui mi ricordo anche che
cosa devo fare qui c'è un cd benvenuto
c'è qualcuno che ha fatto un album
chiamato benvenuto comunque
così come al solito se volete leggere
leggete se non fate quello che vi pare
io non leggo c'è qualcosa che non mi
ricordo cosa serve ok sto mandando tutto
a [ __ ] calmi
devo devo aprire quella porta lì che non
si apre e per farlo
cos'è questo già mi ricordo asi si vede
la miniera quella luce non sembra
naturale ok si praticamente raga adesso
devo riuscire ad aprile che cazzo mi
sembrava di aver visto qualcuno li sotto
dio un tipo di scarico ok c'è qualcosa
qui antidolorifici perfetto e si
praticamente devo aprire quella porta lì
che chiusa e per farlo devo far scattare
il sistema di quello per quando tutto va
a fuoco in dimettiamo il barile di
benzina qui e poi facciamo partire le
scintille e ci dovremmo essere perfetto
ci siamo dopo soltanto qua ci avevo
messo veramente un secolo me lo ricordo
ovviamente lo più sotto e poi ci siano
perfetto
apriti grotta stronza sempre ce
l'abbiamo fatta ci sono i cereali i corn
flakes no ai tasti flakes scesa solo nei
tasti place
qualcuno ci ha mica un cucchiaio del
latte è bloccata va bene c'è la cucina
dove la nutella in ogni individuo game
dove c'è un frigo una dispensa io devo
cercare la nutella
ok ketchup non mi serve un cazzo
perfetto nel forno c'è qualcuno spero di
no
vabbè ci siamo tutto molto pulito e
sterilizzato e che cosa devo fare qui
che non mi ricordo più c'è un cestino
c'è qualcuno frittelle di ketchup
all'afa vj va bene per fare la prossima
volta intanto up rimasta porta ok c'è
una rosa per salvare salviamo dio mio
che cazzo di luce
non vedo niente c'è qualcosa di
rassicurante quella sensazione una
preoccupazione di meno si come nello
scorso penombra è praticamente droga che
cos'è sta roba che cazzo è sta roba
ok ho copiato il testo sullo schermo nei
miei appunti una linea cronologica degli
eventi ok almeno se dobbiamo leggerla ce
l'abbiamo negli appunti perché io adesso
non c'ho voglia via che devo controllare
notifiche su facebook c'è qualcosa dica
addio
la traccia da torcia tra cui si apre
come si accende la torcia f l'ho trovata
ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta
le batterie sono piene anche
fortunatamente però fino a che ci vedo o
meglio non spreca le batterie ok
perfetto manca l'ultima cassette poi
però lo controlla notifiche ok allora
come si logga su facebook non mi
sbilanciate la password lettore cd rom
ricerca controllo blocco forte controllo
blocco porte sboccato bloccata sbocca
inserisci password pif gay
ok password come password errata perché
perché la password errata non è questa
ok
c'è sta roba che non son amico dove si
sbaglia gialappa's raga nessun cd rom
trovato la prima mia ma io l'ho trovato
un cd tipo a questo qui si ok il cd
entra perfettamente allora spero non sia
un porno però proviamo ad aprire lettore
cd tantissimi stand giorno lei ha finito
ha finito
ok ci siano raga introduzione non aprirò
mai cambi password
allora porte 4167 che porta doveva
aprire io
2236 perfetto sbagliati ok nicchia per
un attimo ho pensato che dovevo
riascoltarmi tutto meno male allora 2 3
6 2 3 6 1 1 6 7 ok
1167 1167 1167 1167 perfetto secondo me
la password giusta comunque rapid gates
comunque va bene porta sbloccata ci
siamo ok bene possiamo tornare indietro
ragazze la porta che non mikado quale di
queste due dovrebbe essere questa
ok cazzo esto rumore fastidiosissimo
vabbè
lasciamo ma sono le mie cuffie no non
penso speriamo di no
ok ci siamo ragazzi nei condotti già
siamo in un bunker disperso in una
miniera della groenlandia in più abbiamo
nei condotti a caso nelle fognature del
bunker proprio ok meglio che me ne vado
prima possibile cos'è questo ok batterie
sarà ma non mi ricordo se mi serve meno
apporto per sicurezza
ok ci siamo ragazzi ci siamo cos'è sta
roba
ok perfetto
che cazzo succede ok raga le droghe
inizio non avere effetto
oh mio dio si vede che tutti i
salvataggi che faccio alla fine sei
andato in botta sul serio ma questo è
l'inizio di overture perché siamo oddio
ci siamo ritrovati nella cabina questo è
proprio all'inizio di penombra over tour
che figata
vabbè io ho paura a tornare indietro
comunque anche perché ovviamente sarà
soltanto un sogno visto che sono andato
in porta comunque raga direi che per
questo primo episodio posso finirla qui
vi ricordo che adesso ha date si va
avanti comunque non so niente ero
arrivato fino al in finché non sono
caduta a terra proprio così strafatto
fino a lì c'era arrivato poi non so
adesso in avanti non so proprio più
niente
quindi lei laga che posso concludere qui
l'episodio se vi è piaciuto video come
al solito lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione se
non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
noi ci vediamo al prossimo video bella
ragazzi